good to see you gentlemen
congratulations on this phenomenal
picture thank you so much you're all
pretty young guys but you've been at
this for a while i gotta say working
with steven spielberg must have been
something incredible what's something
that you took from him
working with him every day that you feel
like has made you better at what you do
i mean i i feel like
not being so hard on yourself and
learning to enjoy the process and
learning to enjoy the work that you're
doing and putting in all the love and
passion that you have into it
that's probably the most valuable lesson
i learned from him
yeah he's such a fantastic leader and a
lot of that just comes from like it's
just absolute passion
um
and the he's so creative like the the
joy of the process
uh and then but also yeah he's he knows
exactly what he wants and
he he knows how to talk to people and be
really kind to everyone around him even
when he is
giving you criticism
or
yeah calling you out he's always very
kind
i mean yeah the guy is uh
clearly has had a lot of practice with
working with people making a film is
such a team
effort and uh i think to ansel's point
um
and david's point is that everything
that he does comes from a place of love
um and so
because the work itself is coming from
that place of love that is infectious
and carries down towards everyone and
then in terms of the actual work he
knows exactly when to
butt in when to stay back and let you do
the thing he's very protective
of the work environment and the space
and headspaces of the artists around him
um
it was it was a gift
the relationships between all of you
in this film are so well formed like so
so clear right to see i'm wondering is
did that sort of
the the love and the tension between you
guys come from the page from rehearsal
or was there time spent beforehand sort
of getting into um character together so
to speak it's like all three actually
yeah i mean
yeah except we didn't really get to
rehearse
it seems with each other no so we never
knew what to expect um if i had a scene
with ansel or mike
we would just show up and i was like i
don't know what they're about to do they
might screw me over i don't know what
they have on their mind right now so i
feel like we were definitely all on our
toes waiting to see what the other
person would do which is so realistic
because that's that's what it's a real
conversation in real life if you were
put in the situation you're always kind
of on guard waiting to see what the
other person is going to do and i think
that kind of shows you know yeah but we
had been spending months together
building this thing uh even though we
hadn't gotten to those actual scenes or
storytelling elements yet um
we were very much aware of each other
and
the essence of what each other's person
was and their character was and and
just getting it was that build up that i
think was like oh we're about to you
know get excited to see this thing yeah
yeah and build and building trust and
like because
the like between david and i like that's
a weird relationship on on camera
especially like during the rumble and
like the fact that we were able to have
a relationship outside of that build
some trust and then know that when we
were showing to the rumble like we were
not friends we we were not ansel and
david we were bernardo and tony and but
then at the same time i remember one
time one of my punches didn't go to the
right place and i kind of hit you but
because you love me and because there
was love there
you were like damn bro you got me but
it's all good
[Laughter]
and and finally guys you know
myself being a theater nerd watching it
from the prologue
like the moment you start to see um even
like nods to the old choreography but
then seeing how the new stuff blends in
and makes its own mark was a thrill i'm
curious for the three of you when you
watched it on screen for the first time
knowing the amount of work and passion
that went into it what was your first
reaction
i don't know i feel like we can
i feel like we all kind of had a similar
reaction where we thought that
everything else was perfect except for
ourselves
like when i saw it i thought everything
was perfect except for what i did and
then you thought the same thing yeah and
then you thought the same thing so
i feel like it was kind of interesting
to
to see that because we we just had to
process it because i feel like we went
in to see it and we're gonna like
criticize ourselves we're like what did
i do wrong what did i do right and then
you gotta learn to just not do that you
gotta learn to just sit there and and
enjoy it like another audience member
would um
and just take it for what it is and then
once you do that you
start seeing the beauty of everything
you know
the bigger picture yeah yeah it was
really comforting though like in terms
of i mean going with the whole ensemble
thing comforting knowing like like when
we were on the car and we were all
thinking the same thing we said out loud
no no you're amazing i suck
maybe none of us
[Laughter]
or we all suck
that's awesome well i'm gonna go with
you we're all good because i gotta go
now guys it was a pleasure and uh i
can't wait to watch the movie again
honestly congratulations thank you so
much